افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد عش مواطنين
واصابه اخرين في قصف طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منزل يعود لعائله اسماعيل في
مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع
غزه قتله الاحتلال الحربيه تستهدف قبل
قليل منزل يعود لعائله اسماعيل منزل ابو
احمد اسماعيل في مخيم المغازي وسط
بط دمار كبير
في المنزل والمنازل
انتشال عدد من الشهداء في هذه اللحظات من
هذا
المنزل المستهدف ومنزل عائله اسماعيل في
مخيم المغازي وسط
الحط لا نقول الا ما يرضي الله لا حول ولا
قوه الا بالله وانا لله وانا اليه راجعون
اللهم اجرني في مصيبتي واخلفني خيرا منها
رب ربنا يصبرنا يا رب ربنا يصبرنا شو اللي
صار معكم بالصب والله احنا كنا نازحين من
غزه جايين عن دار اختي ه قاعدين
والطابق اللي تحت كله يعني نساء نساء
واطفال نساء
واطفال اه اجانا بال القصف
اه طبعا نزلنا تحت لقينا طبعا كل الاطفال
وكل النساء كل اشلاء تم قصف طابط النساء
والاطفال بس كلهم اشلاء نحمد الله على كل
حال
الحمد لله على تقريبا العدد اللي كان
موجود في الطابق التب السدا والله يمكن ما
يزيد عن 10
12 تقريبا 12 او اكثر تقريبا تم معرفه عدد
الشهداء اللي تمت انتشالهم والله تقريبا
كلهم شهداء مع طفله عمرها اربع
شهور يعني حيه لقينا يعني الزين مغطى بزين
وسمعنا صوتها فطلعنا
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله تكون على الحياه ان شاء الله